härtere regeln weiche regeln oster ruhe
dann wieder keine oster ruhe lockdown
dann wieder lockerungen das alles ist
deutschland im moment und zwar
gleichzeitig und deswegen sieht auf der
einen seite so aus dicht gedrängt
tausende menschen wie hier im englischen
garten in münchen wo wir gleich auch
live in schalten und dann auf der
anderen seite hatte ausgangs
beschränkung erst in hamburg heute auch
in berlin beschlossen und die kanzlerin
die sich mit einem neuen dramatischen
appell vor ostern auch an sie wendet das
sehen sie gleich ostern steht vor der
tür für kinder es ist die feier des
osterhasen für gläubige das fest der
auferstehung jesu christi und für uns
beide ist es die verleihung des super
wir prämieren heute die bisherigen
aufreger des jahres und es gab schon so
einige highlights des bohrens abgang
jubiläums historische niederlage oder
megans tv interview gleich prämieren wir
hier bei uns das super an mein name ist
nina schenk und mein name ist teilweise
[Musik]
so sieht deutschland im moment aus wenn
man mal aus dem kanzleramt oder aus dem
politiker dienstwagen rausschaut in die
parks auf die straßen
tausende menschen da wie gestern hier in
hamburg vor allen dingen junge leute die
das gute wetter dort einfach genossen
haben und gefeiert haben und ganz
ähnliche bilder heute aus münchen auch
im englischen garten wo auch die
menschen dichtgedrängt waren und auch
dort wie gesagt die frühlingssonne
genossen haben das nochmal hamburg aber
wie gesagt ganz ähnlich heute in ganz
vielen großstädten deutschlands und die
entscheidende frage ist jetzt kriegt die
kanzlerin kriegt die regierung all diese
menschen noch mal zurück in den lock
dauern schaffen die das noch mal wollen
die das nochmal lassen die sich nochmal
darauf ein die kanzlerin zumindest
probiert hast heute mit einer neuen
dramatischen videobotschaft kurz vor
ostern auch an sie die alle bereiten uns
in diesen tagen auf ostern vor
ich nehme an vielen geht es wie mir sie
überlegen was ist möglich zu diesem
zweiten osterfest in der pandemie und
was geht auch in diesem jahr nicht es
wird leider noch einmal ein ostern mit
einschränkungen sein müssen
ich weiß dass darin auch eine große
enttäuschung liegt wir alle hatten uns
schon für ostern mehr freiheiten
gewünscht schließlich dauert die panne -
schon so lang und wir haben monate große
einschränkungen hinter uns wir sollten
sie nicht alleinlassen sondern sie mit
unserem verhalten unterstützen
mit unserem verhalten können wir das
starke wachstum der infektionszahlen
wieder bremsen stoppen und dann umkehren
auch darum geht es an ostern in diesem
jahr das heißt das nun für die nächsten
tage
das heißt vor allem dass es ein ruhiges
osterfest werden soll
eines im kleinen kreis mit sehr
reduzierten kontakten dass ich sie
dringend bitte auf alle nicht zwingen
essen zu verzichten das wir uns alle
konsequent an alle regeln halten
das war es was sie ihnen vor diesen
zweiten osterfest in der pandemie sagen
wollte dass dabei allem worauf wir
wieder und immer noch verzichten müssen
doch auch licht und hoffnung ist
ich wünsche ihnen und ihren liebsten
eine frohe und erholsame osterzeit und
danke ihnen fürs zuhören
ja das war es nicht was sie uns vor
ostern sagen wollte aber das ist eine
ganze menge nämlich eben noch mal ein
dramatischer appell zu hause zu bleiben
und sich möglichst mit niemandem zu
treffen und im hintergrund zu hören wir
werden die nächsten maßnahmen
vorbereitet das ist ein wahnsinniges hin
und her mittlerweile zwischen lockern
und wieder härteren maßnahmen schauen
wir uns nur noch mal die vergangenen
zehn tage an was da alles ablief in
deutschland erst die sogenannte uhr also
geschlossene läden eigentlich ab heute
ab gründonnerstag eigentlich sollte
heute nichts offen haben aber dann kam
ja der aufschrei der große protest
dagegen vor allen dingen aus dem
einzelhandel und die entschuldigung der
kanzlerin und dafür bitte ich auch von
dieser stelle noch einmal die
bürgerinnen und bürger und auch sie
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen um
verzeihung ja und auch markus söder der
bayerische ministerpräsident hat sich
danach entschuldigt dafür dass
zurückgenommen auch ganz ähnlich der
regierende bürgermeister von berlin
michael müller der diese entscheidung
mit der oster ruhe später öffentlich
bereut hat und jetzt die kehrtwende
derselbe müller
der hat heute mit seiner regierung in
berlin mit dem berliner senat eine neue
ausgangssperre entschieden und dasselbe
gab es ja auch schon in hamburg für
hamburg gilt auch demnächst wieder eine
nächtliche ausgangssperre ein hin und
her in deutschland im moment der trend
also wieder richtung härtere maßnahmen
locker und kurz nach ostern noch mal
eine schippe drauf was macht das mit dem
vertrauen der deutschen in die korona
bundesregierung haben wir nochmal ganz
aktuell gefragt und das hier sind die
ergebnisse von unser
meinungsforschungsinstitut insa gefragt
unter 1000 deutschen wie zufrieden sind
sie mit dem co
krisen management der bundesregierung
zufrieden aktuell nur noch 26 prozent
der deutschen also etwas mehr als jeder
vierte und 64 prozent der deutschen 64
prozent der deutschen sind aktuell
unzufrieden mit dem corona
krisen-management der bundesregierung
schauen wir einmal wie sich diese
zufriedenheit der deutschen mit ihrer
corona regierung in den vergangenen
monaten in den vergangenen jahren
verändert hat wie erheblich sie sich
verändert hat die grüne kurve ist die
zufriedenheit die rote kurve die
unzufriedenheit es ging los mit dem
befragungen von uns im vergangenen märz
also im märz 2020 damals große
zufriedenheit mit den maßnahmen 62 64 65
prozent das ist die epic sozusagen in
dieser befragung die zufriedenheit und
damals das ist hier das datum zehnter
vierter dreizehnter fürther 2020 da hat
sich deutschland im lockdown gefunden
also in einer ganz ähnlichen situation
wie heute
damals aber große zustimmung
zufriedenheit mit dem corona krisen
management und dann schauen wir einmal
weiter es geht weiter über den sommer
als die maßnahmen ja locker waren als
wieder deutsche urlaub gemacht haben und
dann der nächste einschnitt hier im
dezember als die zufriedenheit plötzlich
einbrach nämlich mit dem lockdown nummer
2 zweiter lockdown in deutschland und
plötzlich bricht die zufriedenheit 1 49
prozent der deutschen nur noch zufrieden
und dann die wende noch mal im
januar/februar seitdem mehr
unzufriedenheit als zufriedenheit in
deutschland mit den lockdown asam die
rote kurve noch einmal die
unzufriedenheit mit den crooner
maßnahmen mit der chor ohne regierung
die rote kurve die steigt dann im
februar märz weiter an und wir schauen
einmal noch mal bis zu ende
ende märz haben heute den ersten april
also die befragung stammt von gestern
die zufriedenheit bei nur 26 prozent die
unzufriedenheit in deutschland bei 64
prozent also die frage wie zufrieden
sind sie mit dem corona
krisen-management daraus wird
mittlerweile an wie unzufrieden sind sie
mit dieser bundesregierung in dank high
und weil die menschen so unzufrieden in
deutschland mit der politik sind heiden
sich auch viele einfach überhaupt nicht
mehr an die regeln party als gäbe es
kein corona bei lauschigen 23 grad
feiern knapp 500 jugendliche am
mittwochabend in hamburg an der alster
laute musik dröhnt durch den feinen
stadtteil harvestehude die jugendlichen
tanzen abstand oder gar masken
fehlanzeige
an zwei örtlichkeiten in der stadt
jugendliche hatten die gefeiert haben
alkohol getrunken haben und sich in
keinster weise an die eindämmung forden
gehalten haben die polizei rückt an löst
die party auch ein motorradpolizist soll
dabei mit flaschen beworfen worden sein
zum glück wird er nicht getroffen also
bei einem verständnis was wir natürlich
auch für die jugendlichen haben in
dieser aktuellen situation und auch in
dem oder in dem wissen oder in der
annahme dass es für kinder und
jugendliche im moment besonders hart ist
weil die sind natürlich ungeduldig und
die wollen rausgehen und die wollen
feiern und wie wollen sie mit freunden
treffen
das haben wir natürlich irgendwie auch
alle mal erlebt und wir wollten das
natürlich auch aber so eine situation
dass so eine party stattfindet das ist
einfach inakzeptabel und das ist für die
gesellschaft einfach wirklich gefährlich
und da muss man an jugendlichen
appellieren und das tun wir auch sicher
verantwortungsvoll zu verhalten denn
auch sie haben eine verantwortung der
stadt und der menschen gegenüber
das schöne wetter ist lässt die pandemie
vergessen gegen 22 uhr beruhigt sich die
lage schließlich und wie in hamburg
vergangenen nacht dort unter anderem in
harvestehude tausende jungen menschen
draußen heute auch in münchen das sind
bilder von dort aus dem englischen
garten 24 grad sonnenschein klar da will
man nicht zu hause hocken da geht man
halt raus und nicht immer achtet man
dann darauf dass man
ja schön weit auseinander sitzt usw bei
so viel sonne kann man das schon mal
vergessen dort im englischen garten ist
jetzt unser kollege kalk ein
bildreporter im englischen garten zeigt
uns einmal was da jetzt noch los ist und
sagt uns mal die haben gerade die
dramatischen worte der kanzlerin gehört
noch mal diesen appell vor ostern
was würde mit denen menschen dort
passieren wenn die jetzt der kanzlerin
zu hören würden würden die sofort kehrt
machen wieder reingehen
ich glaube nicht ich glaube nicht wenn
man hier mit menschen spricht man kann
es jetzt mal sehen wenn man jetzt mal
reinschalten es sind jetzt da ist wird
er sagen es waren sie über den tag
verteilt so 2000 also im tausender
bereich bewegen wir uns da schon
natürlich 24 grad der letzte tag jetzt
hier mit schönem wetter 24 grad du hast
es angesprochen die polizei die ist
diese unterwegs aber wenn man hier mit
leuten spricht ja die haben hier
volleyball gespielt haben speedminton
gespielt die lagen einfach nur hier am
eisbach und wenn man den sagt bleibt zu
hause oder so er das interessiert die
fast gar nicht die leute wollen sie
beschreiben dass mir gegenüber als so
eine art als sei es ein neues leben
wirklich tatsächlicher weil wir sind
seit november in diesem lockdown und in
münchen ja wir sind jetzt zwei tage in
folge mit der inzidenz über 100 ist es
so ein bisschen wie morgen auf die
zuschauen wieso im lotto ja hat man zwei
richtige oder drei richtige wenn es drei
richtige sind dann gilt ab und dank gilt
ab ostersonntag dann wieder die
ausgangssperre ab 22 uhr abends und auch
die weitere kontakt beschränkung dass
man sich dann nur noch mit einer
weiteren person treffen darf ja inzidenz
lotto nennst du das kann in der tat und
die wahrscheinlichkeit ist leider
relativ gering dass man ja nur im zweier
bereich bleibt also dass man sozusagen
lottogewinn hat am osterwochenende
wie bereitet sich die polizei da jetzt
auf den abend vor wir haben gerade schon
gesehen dass es einzelne die
polizeieinsätze sozusagen da am
englischen garten gab ansprache an die
menschen doch auf die abstände zu achten
usw
was erwarten die beamten jetzt für die
nacht sind da ganz viele beamten
geordert um möglicherweise der
eingreifen zu können wenn der party
stattfinden
ja aber ich glaube dass kaum hinter uns
ist eine
riesige schwarze wolke jetzt donna zwar
auch schon ich glaube dass hier gleich
ja das ist vielleicht auch so was dann
für die politik man hofft also das heißt
auf die politik ist dann quasi kein
verlass mehr man hofft auf höhere mächte
das ist in diesem fall heute der regen
in münchen aber innenminister joachim
herrmann hat es bei uns angekündigt in
bild dass die polizei am osterwochenende
in ganz bayern in verstärkter alarm
stellung ist es sind zusätzliche
streifen abgeordnet worden auch die
bereitschaftspolizei kommt hier zum
einen dass ich auch hier im englischen
garten oder an der isar streife fährt
und es nimmt jetzt auch ordentlich an
vinz us findet und ich glaube dass sich
das ihr gleich von ganz alleine lehrern
wird aber die polizei warnt davor dass
es natürlich trotzdem wenn so viele
menschen draußen sind die konsumierte
alkohol und was hier auffällt es sind
wahnsinnig viele junge menschen die hier
unterwegs sind man sieht kaum ältere und
wir wissen wenn die bisschen mehr
alkohol trinken dann kann das natürlich
auch sein dass es da natürlich auch
abends rund geht wie in hamburg aber das
ist jetzt in münchen eigentlich
erfahrungsgemäß eher seltener der fall
danke karl also da deutet sich dass
söder donnerwetter gerade an im
englischen garten der verdonnert die
menschen da wieder rein zu gehen und
nicht zu dicht beieinander zu stehen
danke danke schön und wir möchten jetzt
mit einem mann sprechen der sich die
maßnahmen nicht länger gefallen lassen
wollte der schuhhändler aus schweinfurt
und wir wollen jetzt herrsche fragen
warum haben sie denn eigentlich geklagt
gegen die maßnahmen ja ich habe geklagt
weil ich mir einfach diese maßnahmen
nicht mehr gefallen lassen wollte weil
sie waren einfach nicht mehr
nachvollziehbar sie waren einfach nur
noch irrelevant und deswegen sind wir
wie einige andere händler wie auch
unseren schuhen konstant den weg vors
gericht gegangen
und sie haben es geschafft hätte sie
dürfen wieder öffnen
warum klagen denn dann eigentlich nicht
viel mehr händler wie sie
also die letztendliche klage die jetzt
durch gegangen ist war eine klage von
unserem einkaufsverband zusammen mit
einem anderen kollegen als
normenkontrollklage fragen sie mich
genau die juristische begriffe was jetzt
wie weitreichend und durchging wichtig
ist es ist durchgegangen ist haben auch
sicherlich viele andere kollegen auch
textil juweliere lederwaren hinter
geklagt diese verfahren sind noch
anhängig wir waren halt jetzt scheinbar
die ersten und ich kann auch nur jedem
empfehlen weiterzumachen weil wenn die
politik nicht auf argumente und konzepte
reagiert dann müssen sie eben mit der
justiz getriezt werden jetzt haben wir
gerade bei ihnen im schuhladen hinter
ihnen ist ja auch ein bisschen was los
sie sind sicherlich glücklich das merkt
man ja auch dass sie wieder öffnen
durften damals als sie die klage
eingereicht haben war die inzidenz sehr
niedrig in schweinfurt mittlerweile ist
die deutlich gestiegen wieder über die
100 rechnen sie damit dass die freude
nur von kurzer dauer war und sie bald
wieder abschließen müssen
ich denke nicht wir werden das sehen wie
ich habe mir die bayerische
staatsregierung darauf reagiert ich
hoffe dass sie nicht reagiert weil
letztendlich ist es ja so
lebensmittelläden haben seit einem jahr
offen da ist infektions technisch glaube
ich nichts passiert man nichts gehört
und wir haben immer wieder darauf
hingewiesen wir haben gute konzepte hier
im einzelhandel und bei uns ist nichts
passiert und deswegen ist es auch gut
dass wir offen haben und jetzt wieder an
unseren kunden dran sind die kunden
wieder die möglichkeit haben etwas
freiheit zu genießen
man kann nicht immer nur verbieten
verbieten verbieten und die leute
wegsperren und wegsperren das ist
sicherlich einfach und ein einfaches
mittel aber es geht einfach nicht mehr
es hat jetzt gereicht herrsche das
können wir sehr gut nachvollziehen haben
sie denn auch sie haben es gerade schon
zum ausdruck gebracht aber haben sie
noch eine klare botschaft an frau merkel
falls sie mögen können sie die jetzt in
die kamera sagen also
es hat ein jahr lang wirklich mit ihren
ministerpräsidenten nur works gebaut
es ist schön dass sie im september
aufhört es müssen jetzt soll daran mache
keine dilettanten die jetzt die ganze
zeit am werk waren die nichts auf die
reihe gebracht haben dass impfen
funktioniert mit das testen funktioniert
nicht solche leute wenn die in der
freien wirtschaft werden die werden
schon längst gekündigt worden oder
abgemahnt worden
solche leute dürfen einfach nimmer unser
land regieren
deswegen ist gut dass bundestagswahlen
wären vielleicht macht ja schon gesehen
an den landtagswahlen wir haben ja auch
noch ein paar landtagswahlen
vielleicht haben auch in bayern noch
eine für mich auch von vorteilen würde
ich es auch begrüßen aber wir müssen
einfach andere regierungen uns fürs land
bringen dass das vorwärts geht weil wenn
alle geimpft sind und weiter getestet
wird dann glaube ich wird auch besser
mit den infektionszahlen und da wo
konzepte sind lasst doch bitte hier den
leuten etwas verantwortung und freiheit
dann sind sie auch nicht mehr so müde
und werden jetzt wie oft war es im
privaten bereich wo er die meisten
infektionen denke ich passieren auch
nicht so fahrlässig sondern sind da
vielleicht wieder
verantwortungsbewusstsein nach einem
jahr ist wirklich bei jedem mal eine
grenze erreicht bei uns hier im handel
definitiv wird sich keiner an stecken
wir haben konzepte
wir begrenzen habe die kundenanzahl
weiterhin noch etwas und ich denke kunde
und auch unsere mitarbeiter im ganzen
handel in deutschland sind sicher und
ich hoffe dass diese urteile für die
bayerischen schulen jetzt eine
signalwirkung hat für deutschland und
für alle anderen händler der kampf muss
auf jeden fall weiter gehen bis alle
händler
geöffnet haben sehr schön das war ein
sehr sehr eindrucksvolle worte und man
will ihn fast raten 1 moderatorin in die
politik zu gehen denn das ist ja das
schöne jeder von uns bürgern kann
mitmachen vielen herz umgang will doch
nicht zu den abend nach st und jetzt
kommen wir zu einem thema was viele
nicht verstehen denn nach mallorca darf
weiterhin geflogen werden
und das eigentlich die ganze zeit doch
es wird nun strenger getestet einen test
muss vorliegen vor dem rückflug unsere
kollegin bild reporterin annika haas hat
das einmal für sie genauer unter die
lupe genommen
tausende deutsche fliegen über ostern
nach mallorca am strand muss nach ostern
eine schutzmaske getragen werden und vor
dem rückflug nach deutschland besteht
nun eine krone test
wer positiv getestet wird bleibt am
boden darf kein flugzeug besteigen
stattdessen werden infizierte
reiserückkehrer in diesem konzern hotel
in palma untergebracht bis ein zweiter
test negativ ist
bild reporterin annika rage ist auf die
insel geflogen um sich von den neuen
maßnahmen ein bild zu machen und mit
deutschen urlaubern zu sprechen
jannis wir uns entschieden die kinder
brauchen ist und wir auch wir uns ganze
jahr über gearbeitet und das haben wir
uns jetzt einfach regeln waren jetzt
auch glaube ich lange genug alle zu
hause haben uns lange gehalten dass das
hier alles in ordnung ist dann kann man
hier auch ganz entspannt urlaub fahren
so langsam kern die urlauber nach
mallorca zurück und auch die deutschen
da wo grad die touristen in den
flughafen rhein gehen da ist auch ein
testzentrum einkaufszentrum weil jeder
reiserückkehrer jetzt ja auch einen test
machen muss bevor zurück nach
deutschland fliegt und einen negativen
corona test braucht das heißt man kann
die direkt am flughafen einen test
machen
für meinen test habe ich mich für eine
klinik in palma entschieden mitten in
der stadt und fußläufig von meinem hotel
erreichbar
hier werden schnelltest aber auch pcr
tests angeboten oder auch bin und mit
meiner adresse und jetzt warten noch
darauf dass meine nummer aufgerufen wird
und ich zum testen gehen kann
nach der wartezeit ist es dann soweit
in der klinik kostet der pcr test 98
euro ein schnelltest gibt es ab 58 euro
bei pauschalreisen übernimmt in der
regel sogar der reiseveranstalter die
kosten
anschließend geht es zum test die
bedingungen er muss 48 stunden vor der
einreise vorgenommen werden
in einer kleinen kabine nimmt eine
klinikmitarbeiterin ein abstrich und
bereitet die probe auf die analyse vor
nach knapp zwei minuten ist es dann auch
schon geschafft
sicher wird mein pcr test gemacht also
mit einen nasenabstrich und mit einem
rachenabstrich und mir wurde jetzt
gesagt wird sich eigentlich nur noch auf
eine sms warten muss diese in 12 bis 24
stunden kommen soll
da sind dann die zugangsdaten für die
website und da kann ich dann meinen text
abrufen wird dann hoffentlich negativ
ist nachdem ich jetzt alle meine daten
auf der website angegeben habe hat sich
ein formular geöffnet und das ist auf
spanisch und auf englisch und ich suche
jetzt hier mal ran
und hier steht noch die taktet das heißt
ich kann mich jetzt auf den weg zum
flughafen machen
annika darf also in den flieger steigen
und zurück nach deutschland fliegen
der nach ostern von deutschland nach
mallorca fliegen will brauchen also eine
maske für den strand vor dem rückflug
nach germany einen negativen corona test
janika ist also wieder zurück und 100
euro für einen test na das ist ja
wirklich absolutes schnäppchen
andererseits einige würden diese 100
euro auf jeden fall bezahlen für eine
ordentliche impfung möglicherweise
allerdings für astrazeneca nicht mal sie
haben das hin und her um astrazeneca in
den vergangenen tagen mitbekommen und
die politik ringt jetzt wieder um
vertrauen in diesen impfstoff dessen
image so massiv angeschlagen ist die
politik ruft dazu auf der
gesundheitsminister zumindest tut das
sich mit astrazeneca impfen zu lassen
der bundesgesundheitsminister hat auch
seine kollegen am kabinett dazu
aufgerufen und er hat ganz insgesamt an
die deutschen gesagt insofern kann nicht
alle über 60 jährigen tatsächlich
ausdrücklich nur bitten dieses
impfangebot wahrzunehmen
diese vorbild zu sein auch als solche
die sich möglichst frühzeitig impfen
lassen und markus söder ganz ähnlich der
sagt irgendwann wird man bei astrazeneca
speziell mit sehr viel freiheit
operieren müssen und sagen müssen wir
will und wer sich traut quasi der soll
auch die möglichkeit haben sich mit
diesem impfstoff impfen zu lassen und
die kanzlerin die s gefragt worden ob
sie sich selber damit impfen lassen und
sie sagt ja klar wenn ich dran bin
da lasse ich mich impfen auch mit
astrazeneca und er hat nägel mit köpfen
gemacht winfried kretschmann der
ministerpräsident baden württembergs hat
sich genau damit impfen lassen heute
auch der
präsident frank walter steinmeier auch
da kam astrazeneca rein in den arm nur
er schert aus horst seehofer ist von
unseren kollegen von der bild am sonntag
gefragt worden ob er sich auch impfen
lassen würde mit astrazeneca und er sagt
die antwort auf die aufforderung des
gesundheitsminister lautet nein ich
lasse mich nicht bevormunden sagt horst
seehofer also keine astrazeneca impfung
beim bundesinnenminister warum aber
immer kann sein dass aufgrund seiner
vorerkrankung das für ihn nicht in frage
kam
ich glaube er wollte ein deutliches
zeichen setzen dass impfen ja seiner
persönlichen individuellen freiheit
überlassen ist und wenn der
gesundheitsminister sagt macht dann sag
ich so der bundesinnenminister kommt
nicht in die tüte
heute prämieren das goldene ei ja wir
haben uns nämlich angeschaut was es so
für highlights dieses jahr schon gab und
man muss sagen in der politik schon so
der eine oder andere politiker richtig
ins fettnäpfchen getreten und wir sind
zu beginn unseres countdowns zum
goldenen ei auch schon thematisch beim
osterfest bzw bei der oster ruhe
kanzlerin merkel will die oster ruhe aus
den da hat sie aber die rechnung ohne
die deutschen gemacht die reaktionen
sind so heftig dass merkel ihre oster
plane für das land ganz schnell wieder
zurücknimmt und vor der öffentlichkeit
und dem parlament um entschuldigung
bitten vieler ist einzig und allein mein
fehler schnell test für alle das
verspricht bundesgesundheitsminister
jens spahn und zum ersten märz und
bricht sein versprechen es kommt zum
streit zwischen kanzlerin und minister
er macht ankündigungen sie kassiert sie
wieder ein
die umfragewerte für sparen stürzen ab
der lachende dritte der discounter aldi
er verkauft schnelltests und bekommt
damit das hin was die regierung nicht
schafft
wie eine karriere endet nachdem sie
gerade erst begonnen hat zeigt uns der
nächste platz die neue co chefin der
linken susanne henning welt so hat in
einem interview absolutes unwissen über
die einsätze der bundeswehr offenbart
auf die direkte frage welche
kampfeinsätze sie denn beenden wolle
antwortete henning welzow lediglich dass
sie nicht alle einsätze einzeln im blick
hätte auch auf die frage ob sie bis
wieviele kampfeinsätze der bundeswehr
aktuell laufen musste die kutsche wenn
der linken passen schon bei den drei
fällen wusste ich nicht wem das goldene
ei am ende gebühren wird aber wir haben
ja gleich noch ein paar andere
kategorien für sie und dann sehen wir
mal am ende keines abgeben musste so
kümmert sich um die eier kehrer ortmann
um die zahlen um die aktuellen corona
zahlen
[Musik]
ja auf der einen seite wird hier in
deutschland ja aktuell viel diskutiert
ob die ausgangssperren über ostern
überhaupt nötig sind auch das reisen in
corona zeiten okay ist oder nicht
aber auf der anderen seite haben vor
allem die mitarbeiter und
mitarbeiterinnen im gesundheitswesen und
in den krankenhäusern die korona
neuinfektionen im blick und die steigen
wieder an das sehen wir hier auf dieser
karte
insgesamt wurden in den vergangenen 24
stunden 24 1300 menschen mit einer krone
neuinfektionen gemeldet das sind über
1600 meldungen mehr als noch vor einer
woche und dementsprechend die kurve
steigt wieder an bei den todeszahlen
sieht es etwas besser aus aber definitiv
auch noch nicht so als hätten wir die
dritte welle überstanden er sind wir
immer noch mittendrin bei 201 todesfälle
in zusammenhang mit dem corona virus
seit gestern ja und auch bei den hot
spots sieht man dass vor allem hier in
lang in der ecke thüringen es sehr sehr
rot ist ruth heißt hier in diesem fall
die institute liegt bei über 100 der
landkreis greiz ist mit einer instanz
von 500 99,6 immer noch der landkreis
mit der höchsten instanz gefolgt von dem
landkreis wartenburg kreis mit einer
instanz von 400 39,59 aber um hier nicht
nur die landkreise zu zeigen die am
stärksten betroffen sind sondern auch
eben ein bisschen positive nachrichten
zu zeigen
zeigen wir hier nochmal einen landkreis
in rheinland pfalz und zwar ist das
bernkastel wittlich mit einer instanz
von nur 19 56 ja und das würden sich
natürlich die meisten kreise und
bundesländer in ganz deutschland
wünschen denn so eine instanz gibt es
nicht oft wie man hier sieht außer im
norden gibt es noch einige landkreise in
einem grünen bereich ansonsten ist schon
viel auf der karte rot ja und was ist
eigentlich in den kommenden ostertagen
erlaubt und was nicht denn die kontakt
beschränkungen gelten ja weiterhin
manche bundesländer haben diese aber
verschärft man darf sich mit einem
weiteren haushalt treffen dennoch sind
es maximal fünf personen die da
zusammenkommen dürfen kinder unter 14
jahren werden da nicht mitgezählt weil
sie ja immer noch nicht als so
ansteckend gelten aber in einigen
bundesländern wurden diese beschränkung
auch wieder verschärft wie zb in
brandenburg und in hamburg hier darf
sich ein haushalt nur mit einer
weiteren personen treffen pärchen abende
sind da also tabu ja und ausgangssperre
gelten ja tatsächlich über die ostertage
auch in einigen bundesländern und
landkreisen alle weiteren infos finden
sie da natürlich immer aktuell auf
bild.de und damit gebe ich wieder zu
euch zurück nena und co ja danke kira
diese zahlen haben wir kurz vor der
sendung aufgezeichnet und sehen jetzt
bilder von der amerikanischen botschaft
hier aus berlin ganz in der nähe am
pariser platz das ist die rückseite
gerade gewesen wilhelmstraße us
botschaft es gibt einen sicherheitsalarm
aktuell dort mitten in berlin an der
amerikanischen botschaft zu mehr
polizisten als sonst dort im einsatz
aktuell die us botschaft hat das auf
bild anfrage mittlerweile auch bestätigt
hat ein polizeieinsatz dort die
botschaft sagt in der nähe der
amerikanischen botschaft bestätigt und
unsere kollegin kyra ortmann diese
gerade noch da im koma da gesehen haben
die ist schnell rüber gefahren von
unserem studio hierbei bild rüber am
pariser platz die jahr rund 200 meter
300 meter dort rüber
kira polizeieinsatz an der us-botschaft
sicherheitsalarm was steckt dahinter
vor gut einer stunde war hier auch noch
die ganze straße abgesperrt vom
holocaust mahnmal bis zum brandenburger
tor darüber
rund zwanzig bis dreißig polizeiwagen
waren hier im einsatz das hat uns ja
auch schon die sprecherin der us
botschaft bestätigt sie hat uns auch
noch gesagt dass sie aktuell genau mit
den deutschen behörden zusammenarbeiten
um diesen fall aufzuklären mittlerweile
hat sich die situation beruhigt man
sieht es hier hinter uns sind nur noch
die ganz normalen polizisten die eben
hier den gebäudeschutz machen vor ort ja
und alles weitere wenn es da neuigkeiten
zu den untersuchungen gibt werden wir
euch natürlich auf dem laufenden halten
ja gerade kommt die nachricht rein kira
dass dort möglicherweise ein rucksack
ein kleiner koffer der auslöser dieses
sicherheits alarms gewesen sein könnte
hier will sie
wir einen beamten der dieses kleine
gepäckstück dort entfernt also offenbar
dies der auslöser für diesen
sicherheitsalarm polizeieinsatz mitten
in berlin an der us botschaft offenbar
keine ganz große sache möglicherweise
ist die ist das foto das uns in diesem
moment entwarnung geben kann danke kira
für diesen moment und deinen einsatz
dort am brandenburger tor
dankeschön
und hier geht es jetzt weiter mit der
oster show mit dem goldenen ei was wir
heute premiere wollen was wollen wir
probieren premieren den aufreger des
jahres denn es ist ziemlich viel schon
passiert in diesem jahr uns auch
ziemlich viele fettnäpfchen willkommen
jetzt zur kategorie show und auch
bohlens rauswurf megans tv lüge oder
sagen wir mal dass etwas misslungenen
comeback der no angels ich bin jetzt
schon sehr gespannt auf platz drei ist
eine band eigentlich auf platz eins sein
will auf platz eins der deutschen
musikcharts denn schließlich haben sie
2021 ihr großes comeback angekündigt
aber wo sind die no angels in den charts
sind sie nicht im radio werden sie nicht
gespielt und damit haben sich für uns
sandy lucy und jessica mit ihrem
comeback versuchen eingelegt
auf platz 2 1 tv ums vor drei wochen
gibt rtl bekannt dass show titan dieter
bohlen nach fast 20 jahren deutschlands
berühmteste casting show verlässt und
die jury in zukunft komplett neu besetzt
wird nachdem rtl bohlens die
entscheidung mitgeteilt hat reicht er
eine krankschreibung ein und sagt die
finalshows ab souveränes verhalten sieht
wohl anders aus
[Musik]
auf platz eins eine tv lüge herzogin
medien behauptet im us-tv drei tage vor
ihrer traumhochzeit im winter heimlich
vermählt worden zu sein und zwar von
erzbischof just in berlin
er behauptet jetzt alles eine lüge er
hätte solch eine eheurkunde nie
unterschrieben
[Musik]
woher könnten diese bilder hier stammen
die wir ihnen jetzt zeigen was könnte
das für ein land sein wunderschönes
abendrot dort haben sie das schon mal
gesehen
einmal kurz nachdenken ich glaube sie
kommen nicht drauf ist ist nord
mazedonien 2 millionen einwohner und die
hauptstadt heißt corp bis hierhin musste
dass kein einziger fußballfan in
deutschland wissen aber das hat sich
seit gestern geändert seitdem hat jeder
fußballfan in deutschland dieses kleinen
land nord mazedonien plötzlich in seinem
kopf drin und das nicht unbedingt mit
besonders positiven erinnerungen den
gestern abend hat sich die deutsche
fußball-nationalmannschaft dort ja ganz
schön blamiert mit einer 1 2-niederlage
gegen nord mazedonien und vor allen
dingen für jogi eine tiefe blamage in
absoluter tiefpunkt vor der
europameisterschaft wir haben heute bei
bild gefragt soll muss der bundestrainer
deswegen schon vor der
europameisterschaft abtreten und 86
prozent der deutschen der befragten hier
bei bild.de sagen tatsächlich jogi geh
doch bitte schon vor der
europameisterschaft und nicht erst
danach und dafür tatsächlich für diesen
frühzeitigen abtritt von jogi löw gibt
es gute gründe
ein bundestrainer auf der suche nach
erfolg lockerheit zuversicht und bald
auch nach einem neuen job nach dem 1 2
gegen nord mazedonien ist auch dem
letzten optimisten klar die zeit von
jogi löw ist abgelaufen
drei gründe grund eins nach dem
wm-vorrunden-aus und dem 0 6 gegen
spanien ist das
1 zu 2 gegen den 65 der weltrangliste
jetzt schon die dritte historische
blamage seiner amtszeit löst zauber ist
verflogen
seine verdienste um den deutschen
fußball sind unbestritten höhepunkt der
wm titel 2014 in brasilien
aber danach konnte das nicht annähernd
bestätigt werden
grund 2 es ist höchste zeit die
europameisterschaft steht vor der tür
und deutschlands fans haben ein
erfolgreiches turnier verdient unsere
nationalmannschaft muss mit einem
selbstverständnis um titel mitspielen
dem erfolg bei der em muss alles
untergeordnet sein
auch der job des bundestrainers und
damit zu punkt 3 2 mögliche nachfolger
für löw während direkt verfügbar sowohl
u21 trainer stefan kunst als auch ralf
rangnick sind angesehene fußballexperten
und könnten sofort übernehmen jetzt
bleiben nur noch drei möglichkeiten jogi
selbst zieht seinen rücktritt vor
falls nein entlässt ihn der dfb oder
drittens wir machen genau so weiter und
vergeigen die em
[Musik]
passend zu ostern gibt es bei uns jetzt
die dokumentation papst benedikt der
sechzehnte seine skandale seine
geheimnisse und sein leben ich würde
sagen das muss man sehen hier bei uns
bei bild plus
[Musik]
jetzt kommen wir zum goldenen eigene
kategorien sport und da war ziemlich
viel los
ich bin jetzt schon gespannt wer am ende
das goldene 1 kriegt vielleicht jugene
auf platz drei ein mega flug ärger
eigentlich wollte der fc bayern nach
seinem spiel gegen hertha von berlin aus
direkt nach doha zu klub wm fliegen doch
brandenburg macht varianz reiseplan
zunichte kurios die maschine des
rekordmeisters gibt's erst am
samstagmorgen um 652 ab also über
siebeneinhalb stunden später als
ursprünglich geplant grund die bayern
bekamen keine startfreigabe am ber für
platz 2 gehen wir nach mexiko erst ein
heftiger torwart blog aber dann diese
epische szene der schiri selbst
verhindert beim nachschuss das tor
die spieler können es kaum fassen so was
gibt es nur nicht
wenn ein bundesligaverein sollen
lachnummer wird schalke 04 steht kurz
vor dem abstieg und die verantwortlichen
machen sich auf einer pressekonferenz
lächerlich vor mir ist es eine ganz
harmlose frage wieder ein journalist
stellt also erst mal ist der erste
zweite nicht richtig sondern der
vertragsbedienstete dritte weiter es ist
ein schicksal das zu tränen rührt die
elfjährige leonie hat gehofft hat
gebannt und hat nun endlich einen
stammzellenspender gefunden
sie ist elf jahre alt hat leukämie und
kämpft um ihr leben doch jetzt hat leoni
endlich wieder hoffnung sie hat einen
stammzellenspender gefunden
seit und einem jahr kann sie nicht mehr
persönlich zur schule gehen denn leoni
ist schwerkrank nicht angeschlagen
sie konnte nicht merken zum auf die
toilette gehen wir für sie mal so sprach
ich gesagt habe das ist nicht normal und
des lebens kranken und gesagt abnehmen
so niedrig dass wir auf die station 100
nächsten tag nach der untersuchung im
klinikum folgt dann die traurige
gewissheit
leoni hat eine aggressive form von
leukämie und muss mit einer
chemotherapie behandelt werden
trotz wochenlanger klinikaufenthalte
steht für die ehrgeizige schülerin fest
im sommer möchte sie unbedingt in die
siebte klasse versetzt werden damit das
klappt sitzt für die tapfere kämpferin
seit einer woche einen lern roboter auf
zwei rädern im unterricht
der verein kolibri hilfe für krebskranke
kinder ev macht das mit mittlerweile 25
robotern möglich jan unterricht
teilnehmen kann und hals in folge die
bild hilfsorganisation ein herz für
kinder unterstützt den verein aufmerksam
durch das kurze video aus erfurt ein
herz für kinder die hier sind ist es ja
und weil ihre eltern als spender nicht
in frage kamen wurde ein
stammzellenspender gesucht
es war ihre eine hoffnung und die hatte
endlich erfolg bei der weltweiten suche
wurde jetzt ein passender genetischer
zwilling für juni gefunden
schon am 29 april wird die elfjährige
transplantiert eine zweite lebenschance
für die todkranke schülerin und dann
kann sie hoffentlich bald selbst wieder
am unterricht teilnehmen und all ihre
freunde persönlich wiedersehen
unsere show neigt sich dem ende zu und
damit auch die verleihung des goldenen
super aus ich bin schon von anfang an
gespannt deswegen würde es mir nicht
verraten ich hätte es verplappert also
quer denken mein persönlicher tipp ist
mengen marke völlig falsch guckst du
noch mal ganz genau an es kann nur einen
geben für dieses kunstwerk muss man
gerade dazu sagen zur osterzeit wenn
verleihen dass für die größten
ausrutscher der vergangenen tage der
vergangenen wochen wäre könnte es sein
haben schon kurz in dieser sendung
darüber berichtet stichwort nord
mazedonien dieser preis kann nur an jogi
löw gehen vor ostern das goldene ei für
den noch bundestrainer
es ist das dritte historische debakel
dass jogi löw nach vielen erfolgreichen
jahren als bundestrainer zu verantworten
hat das erste wm-vorrunden-aus der
deutschen fußballgeschichte in russland
die höchste niederlage seit 1931 mit 0
zu setzen spanien und jetzt dieses 1 2
gegen nord mazedonien die nummer 65 der
weltrangliste die fußball welt lacht nur
noch über uns bei einem bundesligaverein
wäre löw spätestens jetzt seinen job los
und das zurecht und zu recht bekommt er
deshalb von kunz
das goldene flagge so heißt goldenes ei
auf nord mazedonisch zumindest dann wenn
mich google translator nicht in den
april geschickt hat in diesem sinne
krieg rasen wenig denn jogi schöne
verursachen für sie hier und vor ostern
an sie alle vor ostern bis bald
[Musik]